hello everyone I'm Laura Ingram this is
Ingram angle from Washington tonight
it's good to be back but what about The
Disappearing Acts that's the focus of
tonight's
angle all right what we saw over the
weekend was an utter collapse of
whatever shred of credibility the Biden
administration had remaining now they
dug deeper on two blatant lies first the
so-called bipartisan negotiations on the
very border crisis that the White House
itself
precipitated now after mayorcas and
Biden have already green lit what what
is it like really 12 million migrants
into the United States already they
think that they can force Republicans to
agree to a bad deal or get the public to
blame them if they don't what frauds I'm
going to dip into that in a minute but
the second lie involves the defense
secretary's disappearing act uh
president respects the fact that
secretary Austin took ownership for the
lack of transparency he also respects
the amazing job he's done as defense
secretary and now he's handled multiple
crisis over the last Almost 3 years now
um and very much values his advice
cander leadership oh is that right look
we're running a television show not the
Pentagon but if anyone on my senior
staff was missing for four days we'd all
know about it within what maybe 12 hours
now why because first of all we care
about each other uh and also because
we're in near constant
communication and because each staffer
is really important to our daily
production but Lloyd Austin is the
Secretary of Defense the top official in
a 2.8 million person Department he
disappears for 4 days and no one even
notices it now the headlines on this
story mainly focus on the fact that the
Pentagon didn't inform people but I
think more significant is that no one
seemed to notice him gone not the
National Security advisor Jake Sullivan
not the Secretary of State Anthony
blinkin not senior White House personnel
and not the president of the United
States well of course he was busy
getting sunburned in the Caribbean but
imagine disappearing from your office
and the people you deal with on a daily
basis don't even notice for
days so the only conclusion here is that
Austin isn't in regular communication
with any of these people let's call him
the invisible
General well I can tell you who did
notice that our DOD Chief was gone Putin
and GE how embarrassing because we know
they track every step every stumble of
Biden and his
team this isn't how a real superpower
behaves and a real president wouldn't
react to such a dereliction of Duty this
way either but Biden's standing by his
man a White House official confirming to
Fox that President Biden is not
considering firing defense secretary
Lloyd Austin and that the president
would not accept a resignation of Austin
if he were to offer
one but this doesn't mean that they
aren't taking the matter really
seriously people we'll take a look at um
process and procedure here um and uh try
to learn from the experience and if
there's some changes that need to be
made uh in terms of process and
procedure uh we'll do
that okay process and procedure we
should get t-shirts made I'm processing
your procedure now this is what the
angelist told you all along these
officials are asleep at the wheel but
the taxpayers are on the hook for record
spending that we can't afford and we
can't apparently account for we can't
even account for the head of the
dod and where the pentagon's concerned
the sky is the limit after all we have
so many military winds right we can't
count them is that 886 billion now
they're getting but the ultimate insult
here is that Senate Republicans they
don't seem to care that the Pentagon is
rudderless and leaderless at a time when
according to the administration itself
the world is more dangerous than ever
the reality is that the terrorism threat
has been elevated throughout 2023 but
the ongoing war in the Middle East has
raised the threat of an attack against
Americans in the United States to a
whole another level and if that's not
bad enough we just learned that Iran
predictably has ramped up its nuclear
program after Biden dropped the
sanctions good job and with Russia and
China now rallying to Iran's
side yet as all this is happening our
top military official is considered so
insignificant that his colleagues are
unfazed by his absence now when I worked
in the White House a long time ago the
SE DEA was in a daily call with all the
principles but I don't know I guess
everything's going so well for us they
can just blow that all
off now remember the Biden folks thought
hiring firsts was more important than
hiring Excellence they have a vice
president who can't really be trusted
with pretty much anything not even
campaigning she's an embarrassment they
have a press secretary who essentially
has to step aside
for John Kirby when the really hard
issues come up it's so obvious that even
kjp is grousing about it in reports in
the media and now everyone understands
that we have a secretary of defense
who's just a
figurehead I guess kind of like the
president himself right and meanwhile
the Border crisis erupting the president
of Mexico is demanding various
concessions we learn from us on the
issue of immigration translation he's
blackmailing us now this is absurd the
president of the United States has
enormous leverage over the president of
Mexico president Trump after all he
showed everyone how to exercise leverage
by threatening new tariffs on Mexico if
it didn't start helping on the
border and for 25 years I've been
writing and speaking about the fact that
the elites want open borders this is
their policy most of them hate America
and they want America to fundamentally
change
without any input from the voters at all
their political existence is bought and
paid for by people who want to drive
down wages and keep the halves in the
money and the Have Nots without it any
border deal that has the support of
McConnell and Schumer will be rejected
by the Republican voters period where
were any of them by the way any of these
top officials three years ago when the
migrants were lining up at the border to
rush in right before Biden was
inaugurated where was Mitch McConnell
and any frankly in the Senate leadership
when the Biden Administration was making
a laughing stock out of all of us on the
issue of the
border so anything drafted by some
Chamber of Commerce flunky on
immigration is meaningless my orcus will
simply take the money and use it to
settle migrants in the United States
more quickly more efficiently isn't that
great so Republicans should get out of
these ridiculous negotiations we invited
Senator Langford onto the show tonight
he's reportedly leading these talks uh
but he could not join us he did say
though that once the full text is out
he's going to come here and answer all
of our questions I look forward to that
interview look this is nothing personal
toward him or frankly anyone this is an
issue of our country and its
preservation but we strongly recommend
that Langford refus to be the face of
this ask Marco Rubio how that work
worked out for him what was that back in
2013 imagine this audience the audience
reaction in a town hall in Oklahoma City
remember langford's a senator from
Oklahoma let's say he convenes a town
hall in Oklahoma City to sell a border
deal that would have to be enforced by
secretary May orcus what do you think
the reaction of that crowd would be in
Oklahoma we all know what it would be it
would be booze they would say no way
know how don't do it so this is a hot
potato that McConnell has tossed lford
and that he should toss it right back
let McConnell negotiate it think of it
this way why on Earth after the
Democrats did everything in their power
to flood America with millions of
indigents from across the globe would
Republicans ever give Biden an
opportunity to take a victory lab and
then pretend that he's done anything to
solve this problem and by the way if
House Republicans do the smart thing and
say no to this Raw Deal speaker
shouldn't even consider he should say
out of hand he's rejecting it the Biden
campaign is going to hit the airwaves
with the message you you probably
already made the commercials see The
Border's their
fault bottom line you can't make a deal
with someone who has no intention of
fulfilling the terms of the deal I told
you that at the end of 2023 that we're
winning and these two Biden moves
they're covering for an incompetent and
insubordinate cabin official and they're
conniving to pin the blame on
conservatives for their border
these are desperate measures for
desperate people and that's the angle
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else